[Music]
like people go crazy for this great
minecraft
yeah and i've tried to play it myself
but i don't think i don't really
understand
i'm not sure if i understand either okay
it was a long time i was freaking out
like how do i follow up on minecraft
because it's the entire like big like
cultural phenomena you can't
manufacture that this game is beautiful
it is made by single man cause look at
this man this is history
this is my minecraft history dude i knew
that all this world is
all this game is is just a cleverly
constructed sequence of ones and zeros
but i knew that in a way
it's a part of me oh
my god after all these
[Music]
what the [ __ ] years the damage my guy
dude i'm actually five head for putting
my
you can't hurt me in my whole you can't
hurt me in my hole you can't hurt me
[Music]
one spring weekend in 2009 a swedish
programmer
marcus notch person decided to create a
world
uh i don't have any modeling programs to
do the the models i just write them in
code
the cave game as it was known at first
was initially a combination of two games
notch enjoyed
dwarf fortress and infiniminer and yet
notch's goal was not to imitate those
earlier games
it was to create something entirely new
something that would give players the
freedom to literally build their own
reality
and the building blocks of that reality
were all right
there for them it's a it's a toy i would
say
you can build almost anything that you
can imagine
the initial free version of the game was
posted
to tig source forum it wasn't long after
that notch began
charging money for what was now
officially known
as minecraft a name that paid homage to
the other legendary craft titles
that came before it and unlike many of
today's offerings
even those who bought the game in its
earliest incarnation
never had to pay a cent more for full
ownership
something the developers honor to this
day as word of mouth began to spread on
sites like 4chan
and reddit minecraft's popularity began
to rise as well
the biggest advantage of doing things
that we done will release early and
get people to pay to get people who are
more invested in the game we want to
talk about the game
one man's brainchild was suddenly the
obsession
of thousands of people and every one of
them was able to make the game their own
there was something irresistible in the
sheer absolute
freedom of the minecraft experience
whether you wanted to stack your virtual
legos in peace
go on rampages for blocky loot or simply
explore the vast
landscapes of the game it had something
for everyone
this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] okay so i get
the worst [ __ ] world possible
um it seems like i'm not like a desert
wasteland kind of thing
i will destroy you cow sorry obnoxious
yeah give me your armor oh wow i found
like a little island
well it's not really a little island but
it's like sort of like a little island
and then actually it is like a really
big island everybody teleport to me this
is cool
minecraft continued to pick up speed and
the classic version of the game received
several major updates adding features
like the crafting system
that allowed players to make more items
and infinite maps that stretched so
far that attempting to reach their limit
could literally break the game
the beta version of minecraft was
officially launched in november 2010
just a month after notch founded his own
video game development company mojang
i quit my job and went full time and
then
decided that i probably need to start a
company here because i can't keep up
with like the demand on the game
so and now we're seven people and we
have an office and it's a new year and
it's
finally beta the beginning of 2011
marked
an important milestone in minecraft's
development
one million copies sold a number of
improvements were introduced the
following year including
the release of the game's mobile
versions and on november 18
2011 notch announced minecraft's passage
from a beta to a full-fledged game at
the first
ever official minecon are you ready for
the official
release of minecraft
minecraft's success was staggering and
seemed all the more unbelievable
considering it has never been
commercially advertised
to its 16 million users minecraft and
its community were so closely
intertwined
the growth was organic and the game's
dedicated fan base
found a way to ingrain minecraft even
deeper into popular culture
by creating countless youtube music
[Music]
parodies
2012 proved to be an eventful year for
minecraft
the game made its way onto the xbox 360
as well as
ios and android devices minecon 2012
was held at disneyland paris in november
and there was now an official minecraft
lego set
out there for notch however 2012 marked
a personal low point
he went through a divorce that summer
which was only the beginning of a
downward spiral
for the game's creator but in spite of
notch's personal struggles
the game was booming mojang continued to
update minecraft regularly
and looked for ways to bring the game to
even more
players trading horses new biomes
and more minecraft in all its glory
finally became available on playstation
3 in late 2013.
how to attack okay so this is what i
punch with so let's go get some trees is
there a way to run
how do you run uh do you just double tap
or
or does it auto run or oh okay wait
whoa whoa wait minecraft had grown into
something
more than just a game it turned into a
bonafide cultural phenomenon
this is a class where two worlds collide
history
and technology the children at hazeling
field school in cambridgeshire are using
minecraft
to create an indus valley bronze age
settlement
elite just playing for like a really
long time
and then they tell you to get off and
they're like oh come on
i don't want to stop but what notch
realized was
that the game had absorbed him entirely
instead of being marcus person
he had turned into the guy who made
minecraft
i looked you up on the internet and
stuff and it seems like
there's quite a lot of bitchiness in
your world like quite a lot of people
like
i hate him he created minecraft how dare
he not be
me you know notch was personally blamed
for
any and every issue within the game
despite having stepped away from working
on minecraft some time ago
and the solution seemed obvious hand
minecraft
over to someone else so just when that
happened
everyone's giving me so much like crap
online or this one no
this is not worth it anymore so just
tweeted kind of jokingly like
who wants to buy the company right the
tweet may have been a joke
but the response was dead serious
microsoft offered to buy mojang
for an astronomical 2.5
billion dollars because it's it's such a
huge thing
it's a cultural phenomenon it's like
buying
lego or buying disney or something like
that it's such a an institution
particularly to the younger audience and
microsoft knows that
with microsoft's backing mojang
continued to produce quality minecraft
content for its players
and notch could enjoy his newfound
wealth and finally
focus on other pursuits but even being
a billionaire wasn't enough compared to
being a god
minecraft was such a massive
accomplishment notch was still living in
the shadow
of the enormity of his own creation his
increasingly erratic social media posts
raised questions
about how well notch was handling the
separation
from his life's greatest achievement and
now i realized oh this
fun to go party it's not a sane way to
spend money but it's
fun i figured like when i was younger we
didn't have a lot of money at all
if i ever get rich i'm not gonna be one
of those boring rich people doesn't
spend money right
i don't try to compensate for giving to
charity as well so i feel better about
myself
minecraft in the meantime saw its
popularity online
wane somewhat its player base was still
massive
mojang was still doing what it always
did updating the game and
making sure the player experience
remained as engaging as ever
and you will fight your way through in
kind of
like a dungeon crawling genre so it's
it's kind of like a
top-down dungeon crawler so you're
traveling around various environments
yeah packing up mobs yeah yeah
absolutely it's there
but all those kids who initially got
into minecraft and made it as big as it
was
were growing up there were newer cooler
games on the horizon
for example fortnite was drawing a lot
of minecraft once
faithful content creators towards its
seemingly greener pastures
for some of these older players playing
minecraft became
something like a guilty pleasure but the
sun
hadn't set on minecraft forever far
from it
[Music]
in 2019 the game celebrated its 10th
birthday an event notch wasn't invited
to
as microsoft was trying to distance
itself from
minecraft's highly controversial creator
going as far as removing his name
from the game's splash art while
excluding notch from what was
essentially the celebration of his
life's most monumental accomplishment
may seem like a step too far his online
persona had taken
a dark turn over the years racism
conspiracy theories not just social
media presence had deteriorated
to the point of no return when you look
at the game today it shows no
signs of stopping down with new updates
coming out
just bringing and inviting new people to
the game
all while notch just slowly fades away
day by day
the exact opposite of what's happening
to his game
minecraft notch's troubles aside the
year gave minecraft's team
many causes for celebration the game's
youtube
renaissance being chief among them
pewdiepie
a youtuber notorious for sending various
games into the stratosphere of online
popularity
simply by playing them decided to upload
his first minecraft video
in years i have not played minecraft
properly
in ever i played the game when it was in
alpha
that's right hipster notch supporter i
think a lot of it has changed i'm not
sure
the so-called pewdiepie effect did its
job and before long
the avalanche of creators who wanted to
stack cubes for their viewers
brought minecraft out of its relative
obscurity
and back into the limelight
sorry i'm so wow that was the most 12
year old twitch viewer thing of me ever
yeah
so basically back in like 2011 i used to
play
a lot of minecraft it's been a very very
long time
since i've done a single player solo
survival effort myself
a lot of new stuff has been added
apparently so i thought just for a bit
of a lull
i would play
is it worth getting back into overwatch
again
how is he so dumb what a degenerate dog
ah this is gonna be mount myth ah dude
this is gonna be sick
and for those who once enjoyed playing
minecraft themselves
watching their favorite content creators
stream the game from their childhood
kickstarted
a wave of nostalgia sending droves of
older players
back around the block minecraft was cool
again
challenge runs strategy guides pranks
minecraft offered both new and
established streamers unlimited
opportunities
to create the kind of content they
wanted on their channels
i don't even oh okay okay all right i'm
in
i'm in the game okay wait so the
graphics are actually this bad
this is normal oh no
what is that this is the oldest version
of minecraft
look at how bland it is it's so old
there's no hunger bar
for those who played it as kids the
extensive updates mojang implemented
over the years
made the game feel fresh without taking
away what originally endeared players to
minecraft
its simplistic yet unique design that
made the possibilities
virtually endless and while notch likely
never
intended for his own life to take the
twists and turns that it had
ultimately minecraft provided players
with exactly the sort of freedom
to choose their own path that its
creator originally intended for his game
the freedom to literally build their own
world
dude i was so sad when this hard drive
died
because look at this man this is history
this is my minecraft history dude
there have been plenty of attempts to
imitate the game's success
but none have ever come close in the
decades since its creation
minecraft went from an indie darling to
the best-selling
video game ever created it gave us
unforgettable moments of both
triumph and failure and crossed over
into other parts of pop culture that we
encounter on a daily basis
the sheer magnitude and complexity of
what
one man created over the course of a one
weekend
in 2009 makes minecraft an
untouchable cultural building block of
our time
to millions of people out there
minecraft
is more than a game it is a living
breathing testament
to the power of imagination put me in
some random world i've never explored
you can add weird new items i'll never
know how to use but to me
it's not really minecraft until that
music starts fading in
and i'm pulled back into a world when
nothing really mattered
when everything was easy and when
i was happy
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you
won't find anywhere else hit up our
instagram twitter
and facebook pages